- Are these questions all
right for you, by the way?
- They're perfect.
- They're stupid, I
know they're stupid,
but it's in the show.
- I've been drinking
so much they starting
to start like smart questions.
(laughing)
It's starting to sound
like Jeopardy around here.
$200, Alex.
- What's up?
I'm Chris Distefano, this
is Yamaneika, no last name.
We're at Skinny Dennis in
Williamsburg, Brooklyn.
I voted for Hillary, even
though I don't look like it.
You gotta believe me.
This is Stupid Questions.
All right, this is really dumb.
- Okay.
- Let's say me and you were
dating, which is possible.
- That's the stupid part of it?
You got a thing with
big black women?
- No, I don't, no I don't.
- I don't know if I
wanna be here anymore.
- I swear to God, I
don't have a thing.
- Why is that a part
of Stupid Questions?
- All I'm saying is black women.
First of all I don't assume
gender, I like people--
- Oh now I'm not even a woman.
You don't assume that I'm
a woman, all this breast?
Come on.
- I know, I got big tits too.
- You always make it
about you Chris, I can't.
- I'm sorry.
Would I get a second
date, would I get a se--
- You not even gettin' a first
date off this question, so.
- A second date,
everything's the same,
I look how I look except
I have a ponytail.
I turn like this you
notice, boom, ponytail.
Would you go on a
date number two?
- No.
- You wouldn't?
- Why would you have a ponytail?
- I don't know, what
about every time
I mention my mother
to you, I whisper it.
I'm like, you've
gotta meet my mother.
- Your breath
smells really good.
If you whispered like that
in my nostrils, yeah, maybe.
- Mother.
(upbeat music)
- Would you rather have hiccups
for the rest of your life
or feel like you have to
sneeze but not be able to
for the rest of your life?
- Or the third option,
I just kill myself.
Don't nobody wanna
keep tryin' to pretend
like they gotta sneeze
and not sneezin',
not sneezin' and have--
- Can I be honest with you?
There was a time recently,
like a month ago,
where I felt like I had to
sneeze for like two weeks
and I could not sneeze.
I went to like three doctors,
I thought I had a brain tumor.
How wild is that?
- You gotta get outta
your environment.
(upbeat music)
- This next stupid question
is actually perfect.
- Okay.
- What's the weirdest thing
I would see in your home?
- I have a cat fountain.
My cats, they need
fountain water.
They put the,
meow, meow, meow, meow.
- That is pretty weird.
I'm allergic to cats,
is that a problem?
Uh oh, did we just
change things?
- You're not allergic,
that's bullshit.
Somebody told you you
were allergic, you're not.
Nobody's allergic to a cat.
- I'm allergic to
cats and fake plants.
- What about fake hair?
Yeah.
- Smells good.
- Yeah that's black
woman glory, yeah.
And a couple of bills.
- Now is it real or not real?
- You never ask a
woman about her hair.
Where did you grow up?
Get your mother on the phone.
- The next stupid question.
I'm gonna ask you this once.
(laughing)
- Which one of these
women is my mother?
- Stop!
Oh my God, well we know--
- [Chris] I could be adopted.
- Well we know
you're not adopted
because nobody
would pick you up.
This is Bruno Mars' mom.
(laughing)
This is Nancy Reagan's mom.
- [Chris] Oh my God.
- I don't even know why
this lady's on a cell phone,
she like she was born back
when they were usin' tin cans.
(sighing)
- Come on.
- I think this is your
mom, young and hip.
- Wow, that is not my mom.
- [Yamaneika] Damn.
- But my mom is so happy
that you picked that lady.
- This is actually my mom,
just your classic human
resources manager.
- Yes.
- Lovin' her dog, ya know.
I was hopin' it wasn't her
because the worry her eyes say,
please don't bring
a black girl home.
- Sorry Mom.
- Guess who's comin' to dinner?
- Come on.
(smooching)
(upbeat music)
- Yamaneika, thanks so much
for playing Stupid
Questions with us.
Did you have a good time?
- I had an amazing time,
thanks for having me.
- You know what?
- What?
- Throughout this whole
night, I've been having
a caricature artist draw
out the entire scene.
Just for no reason, I
just wanted to do it.
And I wanna show it to you now,
it's like my goin' home present.
I'm actin' like I'm not, yeah.
Look at that.
(gasping)
How unbelievable is that?
That drew out the
whole scene for us.
- I love this, this is me.
She thinks I'm beautiful.
- Oh that's your hair.
Oh she's got everything
in your hair.
- What do you mean,
oh that's my hair?
- This is your hair.
- What did you think this was?
- I don't know.
(upbeat music)